*sniff*
Oh yeah, there’s totally a bomb in there.
Most people just assume we humans have a terrible
sense of smell.
But, that’s just wrong.
Our sense of smell is super powerful, maybe
equal to dogs.
Researchers at Rutgers are challenging the
idea that “dogs and rodents [are] some of
the best sniffers in the animal kingdom.”
They posit humans are right up there with
them.
Throughout history, human smell has been consistently
downplayed.
For example, you may have heard humans can
smell 10,000 scents…
Which is so wrong.
10,000 is a rough estimate gleaned from experiments
done in 1927 with 6,561 scents (they rounded
up to 10,000)!
It was a guess and wasn’t even empirically
tested.
Smell is difficult to quantify… unlike the
three colors of light, or specific wavelengths
of sound, smell doesn’t have a concrete
base to start and experiment with -- every
nose is different!
Things like humidity, shape, size, age, and
even language, individual experience, and
behaviors can all mess with nose sensitivity.
So, scientists run test after test and determine
the odor detection thresholds -- measured
in parts per million.
1ppm is one odor molecule in one million!
Drinking alcohol’s ODT (it’s actually
ethanol) is 10.0ppm, which is pretty high,
with some things we can smell way less than
that!
For example, studies found humans can detect
as little as zero point zero four parts per
million of ammonia.
That’s equivalent to dropping a shot glass
of ammonia in an olympic swimming pool...
Knowing 10,000 scents is way wrong, in 2014,
scientists ran a new set of studies and found
average humans can discern One Trillion scents.
They did this by mixing 128 different scents
in groups, and then used math to find what
they believe is the “lower limit” of our
sense of smell.
To go back to sight and sound…
We know we can I.D. several million colors
and half-a-million tones, this means smell
is more sensitive than both.
Okay, bringing it back to dogs.
It seems to me, we use dogs to sniff things
not necessarily because they’re the best
at sniff, but because they’re easier to
train to be sniffers…
According to the book Canine Ergonomics: The
Science of Working Dogs, dogs can’t easily
distinguish between the explosive C4, and
other concentrations of the main chemical
in it cyclbohexanone, but humans -- we can!
It smells like acetone and peppermint and
tests show our bottom odor threshold is zero
point 88 ppm!
Like two and a half soda cans in a swimming
pool.
Plus, humans could talk it out.
We could say, hey, I think I’m getting something
here… dogs can’t do that.
Another study found, with the right training
we humble humans can track a scent through
a grassy field, while blindfolded!
They tested human’s ability to track a scent
and found not only could we do it, but their
humans got better with practice and training.
Which brings us back, again, to canines vs
humans.
These researchers are saying we should stop
thinking canines better at smelling than we
are.
But why do we use them then?
Because we can train them more easily!
Slate reports, a 10-week training program
exposes dogs to explosive compounds “up
to 120 times a day, in amounts ranging from
1,000 pounds to 1 gram.”
Using behavioral training, when the dog identifies
the explosive amongst a bunch of other compounds
they get a treat.
Over weeks and weeks, the dog is trained to
smell a compound, and on repeated training
they can learn around a dozen smells.
You could do this with humans, but who would
want that job?
Obviously, more research is needed on smell.
But if you walk away from this video I hope
you realize your sense of smell is on par
with other mammals -- which is to say… it’s
incredible.
Are you smelling what I’m cooking?
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
But if smell is so powerful, could we smell
space?
What would space smell like?
Julian hit up the YouTube space in LA without
his glasses or beard for some reason to find
out, here.
Are you convinced?
How do you feel about your sense of smell?